foreign
open up open up
your hands
let me see your hand let me see your
hand
let me see your hand
slow
maybe a fast back passenger hey move him
move him
no hold on not yet oh she buying him
stop moving stop moving stop moving here
ain't nobody even did nothing so I'm
just saying hold on Notch get out of the
car I'm about to get out of the car can
I get out get out let's go show me your
hands
foreign
[Music]
no no
no
yes
what's up
outside
all right
it appears okay yeah I'm good
hey get away from here
[Applause]
SpongeBob
understand
okay
oh very okay
we're not
over right now
[Applause]
[Music]
get out
this car is off put your feet around
oh shit
foreign
oh
man okay
Caraballo good you're okay
are you good no I'm good
did we got all three
do we have all Theory
all right
priority we'll take everything else you
get taken care of that
um
I want to make sure this guy gets
free
do we have all three I got one right
here you got one over here too
oh
[Applause]
right now
oh
one run
no no there was only three yeah we got
one here and two there
you good I'm good go already go over to
EMS I would like to find my glasses you
guys
go over and talk to um
are yours